it was just an ordinary night at site 19
and dr smith was hard at work in his
office the overhead light was just about
ready to give out the bulb dim and
flickering but there was no one
available to change it at the moment so
he would just make do besides he only
had a little bit of work left to finish
hunched over his desk eyes blurry and
head aching from too many hours of
staring at a screen he was ready to wrap
up this report and finally get home for
some well-deserved rest the constant
anxiety of working with some of the
scariest monsters in the world was one
thing but the hour spent writing
paperwork on the monsters was an
altogether different kind of terrifying
most of the research staff had left for
the night and only dr smith and the
usual security team remained in the
building there was no sound except the
click of his fingers on the keys his
occasional exhausted sigh and the
infrequent sound of footsteps in the
hall outside as a security officer made
his rounds dr smith leaned back in his
chair stretching his arms over his head
and feeling his back crack almost done
he recalled dimly a thermos of tea he
had left on the shelf behind him perhaps
that would be the kick he needed to
finish this workup and get home to his
bath his books and his pet cat roger he
swiveled his chair around preparing to
stand up and retrieve the thermos when
he suddenly came face to face with a
nightmare there less than an inch from
him was a smooth featureless face black
as the night and devoid of any
expression it was hunched over its face
peering into him despite not having any
eyes itself without a sound without so
much as a creak of the door this thing
had come into his office and appeared
behind him waiting for him to turn
around and see it dr smith let out a
shriek of terror knocking his chair over
as he scrambled to get away from the
intruder his heart pounding in his ear
as he tore past the dark figure yanking
open the door to his office and taking
off running down the hall he called out
for help for someone anyone to come
several security personnel heard his
cries and rushed to see what had
happened they found a shivering dr smith
babbling about a demon in his office and
repeating it doesn't have a face over
and over again once he had calmed down
and finally been given that cup of tea
dr smith was informed that as stressful
as that encounter might have been he was
never really in any danger we don't have
another scp-173 on our hands here
thankfully this statue isn't murderous
or even violent to the best of our
observational ability we've determined
that this particular surprisingly mobile
statue is just kind of a jerk scp-650
nicknamed the startling statue is a
stylized black statue of a humanoid
figure standing at 167 centimeters tall
it has no hands or facial features its
arms extending in rounded points and its
face and head a smooth surface like that
of a mannequin when the statue is
dormant or at least resting and waiting
for its next chance to move it stands
straight and reaches upwards head tilted
up as if its non-existent eyes are
watching the sky attempts to determine
the materials of the statue is made of
have proved inconclusive some tests show
an impossibly large combination of
different materials where other tests
came back with no matches for any
recognized materials at all if no one is
observing the statue it will move to a
place immediately behind whoever is in
the room with it switching its pose to a
more threatening one it moves silently
and no one has been able to capture
evidence of its method of locomotion all
that is known is that it does in fact
move and it always appears extremely
close to the subject of its interest in
order to provoke a strong flight or
fight reaction the statue seems to have
no interest in harming those it
frightens never touching or directly
interacting with anyone it only seems
interested in startling its victims if
you can even call them victims it can be
unpleasant to be unexpectedly frightened
like that sure but you get the same
experience at most halloween attractions
or horror movies and people pay good
money for those several trials were
conducted in order to determine the
statue's pattern of behavior in a trial
an scp foundation agent was assigned to
stand in the statue's containment unit
and watch the object for a period of
time when prompted by a researcher in
another room speaking to them via radio
they were ordered to look away from the
statue once cleared to look at the
statue again they were ordered to look
around the room and report where it went
and what it was doing in most of the
experiments the statue appeared directly
behind the personnel angled with its
arms reaching towards them and its head
glaring down at them as if about to
attack in nearly every trial the statue
hit the same position and the agent
looking at it was startled to the point
of screaming there was even talk of
cutting footage of all the screams
together into a video that would be
shown at the company christmas party
however in three cases the statue
adopted a different pose as well as a
position in the room much to the
surprise and confusion of the team
conducting the experiments when agent
dunn was assigned to observe the statue
he was asked to close his eyes for five
seconds and wait for scp-650 to move
when he opened his eyes the first thing
he did was whirl around and look behind
him having heard about the results of
the previous tests however when he
turned to face the statue there was
nothing there he turned back around to
his original stance preparing to radio
command and tell them the statue was
gone when he let out a yelp of surprise
there at the table in the corner several
feet away was the statue it was lying on
the table with its arms behind its head
as if relaxing with the area considered
to be its face turned directly towards
dunn unsettled by the surprise and
definitely uncomfortable with how the
statue seemed to be looking at him he
left the room without another word at
another point in the trials agent riley
pulled the short straw and was told to
enter 650's containment she stood in the
center of the room and stared at the
statue in front of her for a long period
of time when given the command she
closed her eyes and waited for a
duration of 30 seconds much like agent
dunn her first instinct on opening her
eyes was to turn around and look behind
her ready to see the statue there
instead however it was sitting on a
chair at the other end of the room the
points where its hands should be neatly
folded in its lap its body was facing
away from agent riley but even though
she was looking at what could have
easily been the back of the statue's
head she later reported the distinct
sense that it was looking at her though
she didn't scream like her collies had
when it was their turn to watch the
statue she confessed to feeling an
overwhelming sense of unease and her
hands would not stop shaking for the
next several hours these two instances
of the statue adopting a casual posture
and keeping its distance from its
observers were bizarre but the final
break from the statue's usual behavior
was the strangest of them all agent cho
was sent into scp-650's containment and
told the stand with his back against the
wall of his choice the plan was to
determine what the statue would do if
its unusual favorite position just
behind the observer was no longer an
option if there was no space behind
agent cho then the statue could not turn
up there once he was settled into his
spot and had been watching the statue
for several minutes agent cho closed his
eyes for exactly one minute when he
opened them he immediately scanned the
room to see where the statue had gone it
was not at the table or the chair nor
was it standing in its original place in
front of him finally he spotted it the
statue was huddled in the corner of the
room curled up in an approximation of
the fetal position its head was down and
its arms were held up in front of its
face as if trying to protect itself
though he could not explain why agent
cho got a distinct impression that the
statue was afraid his stomach dropped at
the site and he would later admit to his
supervisor that he briefly thought about
trying to comfort scp-650 somehow the
impulse passed but cho was left with a
mixture of anxiety and guilt as if he
had done something wrong and upset the
statue the sensation did not pass until
he was out of the room it is not
entirely clear why the statue chose
these alternative poses during these
particular experiments the prevailing
theory among the research team is that
these are simply other tools in its
arsenal methods that it can use to
elicit a strong reaction from a person
who is less likely to be startled by its
usual trick following the incident with
dr smith scp-650 was upgraded from safe
class to euclid class just to clarify
for people in the back euclid-class scps
are not necessarily considered to be
dangerous but require more effort to
contain than objects classified as safe
most scps that display autonomy or
independent thought but are not overtly
hostile towards humanity are classified
as euclid along with its updated status
special containment procedures have been
employed in order to keep this startling
statue from making any more surprise
escapes
scp-650 is to be stored in a locked room
four meters by four meters it is to be
kept under constant surveillance by at
least three personnel at any given time
standing so that the scp and at least
one of the observers are visible to them
at all times they are allowed to watch
the statue remotely via security camera
as long as they remain focused on the
scp this method is only to be employed
in case of emergency a great deal of the
foundation's budget was dedicated to
maintaining up-to-date containment
facilities for scp-650
as demanded in a note from dr smith in
the official file for scp-650
the note reads i don't give a flying rat
about the budget keep this damn thing
contained turning around in a dim office
to see this thing a half inch away from
your nose is guaranteed to take years
from your life and given what we deal
with we don't have many to spare so what
does the startling statue want why does
it use its power of mobility to scare
people but never do anything beyond that
no one is certain and the foundation has
too many other fires to put out to
bother looking further into a clearly
benign entity unfortunately there are
questions about scp-650 that will never
be answered and there is so much about
it we will never know one thing is for
sure though if you find yourself alone
in a room with an unsettling statue you
had better keep an eye on it just in
case now go check out
scp-173 origin story how scp-173 got to
site-19 and scp-680
haunter in the dark for more of the scp
foundation's strange and frightening
statues